oh  look at that  notch that already looks thicker than  this m1 macbook pro right here we have  that new mac safe right there you got  the two usbc's headphone jack look at  that increase in real estate wow that  display just looks so much more  immersive look at how thin those bezels  are the macbook pro text is gone but i  am noticing that it's also much darker  the keys themselves are more dark the  new black well surrounding all the keys  that is a totally unique look and as far  as the size of the chassis itself it's  actually wider this way and taller or  deeper that way and the display is a  little bit taller and that enabled apple  to add the function keys back the  physical function keys they've switched  out the little square touch id button  for a new larger one with a little  circle the speaker grilles are much  wider the trackpad is identical